PROFESSOR: Good moRning.
Again, we're left with
a little stub of
chapter six to finish.
This was our first chapter on
binary linear block codes.
Very briefly, last time we
developed the family of RM,
Reed-Muller codes, parameterized
by R and M.
These are codes of length two
to the M, and distance 2 to
the M minus R for all reasonable
combinations of M
and R, integers.
And the reason I do these first
is because it gives us a
nice big -- in fact,
infinite --
family of codes that kind
of cover the waterfront.
Let us see what we can
reasonably get in terms of the
parameters n k d in codes.
And, of course, n k t d tell us
most of what we know, want
to know about the performance
of moderate complexity codes
in terms of coding gain.
And it's easy to see that among
these codes, we have
sequences in which the coding
gain goes -- the nominal
coding gain goes to infinity.
And we also know that there's
at least one sequence, the
bi-orthogonal sequence, for
which the effective coding
gain completely closes the
gap to the Shannon limit.
And in all likelihood, there
are many such sequences,
though I'm not aware of the
actual result there.
So it seems like we might be
almost finished here, except I
asked about what possible fly
there could be in this
ointment last time.
And one of you alertly reported
that we still really
hadn't worried about decoding.
And the implicit decoding
algorithm here is minimum
distance decoding.
Exhaustive minimum distance
decoding.
We basically have to compute the
minimum distance to each
of the 2 to the k code words.
And that's going to get a little
tedious as soon as k
gets up to 16 or 107
or whatever.
So it was recognized pretty
early in the development of
coding theory that this was
the essential problem.
The problem is not to construct
codes whose
performance under maximum
likelihood decoding is near
that of the Shannon limit
-- you can use
random codes for that.
But in constructing these more
algebraically structured
codes, what we're really trying
to do is to facilitate
the decoding problem, which
is the central problem.
We need to find a
decoding method
that is actually feasible.
And, of course, Shannon didn't
address that at all.
He just addressed the ultimate
potential of these codes with
the optimal decoding technique
and didn't worry about its
complexity.
All right.
So I'd say the fundamental
problem here is decoding
complexity.
Now, one of the --
an awful lot of the early work
on coding was about binary
codes, of course.
But it also considered them in
the context of binary decoding
algorithms.
In other words, what's assumed
is what you send as a series
of bits and what you receive
as a series of bits.
That's not the picture we have
here in this course, where
what we receive is a series
of real numbers.
Because we're going over a
continuous additive white
Gaussian noise channel.
Of course, there are channels
which are inherently digital,
at least by the time the coding
engineer can get his
hands on them.
What he's presented with
is a string of bits.
So it makes sense to consider
codes for bit error
correction.
Classic codes of this type
are, first of all, the
repetition code.
If I send this --
if I use the 7 1 7 code, the
repetition code of length 7,
I'm going to be able to correct
up to three errors.
Three bit errors.
Because four bits are still
going to be correct.
In a majority vote, we'll
do the decoding.
Most of you have probably
seen Hamming codes.
These are codes with minimum
Hamming distance 3.
That means if you make one
error, you're still within the
Hamming sphere of radius 1
around the original code word.
That's disjoined from all the
other Hamming spheres, and so
in principle you ought to be
able to do single error
correction with Hamming codes.
And there are very simple
algorithms for doing that.
OK.
But that may be what
you have to do.
The final point of chapter six
is that in the additive white
Gaussian noise context,
that's not what you
want to do at all.
And I just want to say a few
words about that because this
is one of the Achille's heels
of a lot of classical coding
theory, which was addressed
to the binary
in, binary out situation.
So let's talk about the penalty
for making hard decisions.
That is, by hard decision, we
mean a binary decision.
0, 1, plus or minus 1.
And I'll do this fairly quickly,
but in a way that I
hope will stick.
Let me draw our block diagram
of our coding scheme.
We've got a code.
We've got an encoder,
which basically
puts out a code word.
An n-tuple in the code.
I'm going to consider
the individual
elements of this n-tuple.
They're just elements of the
binary field F2 And we go
through our standard 2-PAM map,
which maps them to s of
xk, which is going
to be in plus or
minus alpha in general.
Just plus or minus 1.
Doesn't matter up to scaling.
In order to send them, we're
going to send this sequence of
real numbers over the white
Gaussian noise channel.
And as a result, we're
going to get out s --
let's call it a received
symbol --
rk, which is the transmitted
symbol plus some Gaussian
noise symbol, nk.
This is a real number.
And then --
then what we do?
Now we're into the decoder.
This is what we received, so
it's free to us to choose what
to do next.
I'm going to say observe, first
of all, that without
loss of generality, we
can decompose rk
into a sign and magnitude.
So this out here is going
to be a sign of rk.
And this is going to be
the magnitude of rk.
And let me just give
this a name.
Let me call this yk, and let
me call this beta k.
OK.
So what is this?
This is in plus or minus 1, and
this is in the positive
reals, so the non-negative
reals.
OK.
And clearly, if I keep both of
these, I haven't lost any
information.
This is just a way of
representing rk in sign and
magnitude form.
Now, this is what's called
the hard decision.
Actually, let me do
this differently.
Let me pass this through the
inverse to a 2-PAM map.
So out of this, I get a yk,
which is in F2 OK.
Either of these --
the real sign or the binary
hard decision --
could be considered to
be the hard decision.
Now, what am I doing here?
I'm saying, well, if you force
me to make a guess on whether
this individual transmission was
sending a 0 or 1, this is
the most obvious guess.
If I send --
here's minus 1, here's our minus
alpha, here's plus 1 --
if I sent a plus 1, then my
maximum likelihood per bit
decision would be to decide
the plus 1 was sent.
If I get a positive sign in --
what I'm really mapping here is
rk, and minus 1 if I get a
negative side.
So that's what's called
a hard decision.
I'm going to decide right here
what I think it was, what it
most likely was.
And this is the best
way to do it.
Just take the sign.
This here is a real valued
weight, often called the
reliability, which is
helpful to retain.
That's the main point
of what I'm going
to talk to you about.
If this is 0 --
that means what we received
was right on this boundary
between the positive and
negative side --
then the reliability is 0.
In likelihood terms, that means
it's equally likely that
what was sent was a plus
1 or a minus 1.
So in some sense, we get
no information when the
reliability is 0.
Fails to discriminate between
plus 1 and minus 1.
The larger this is, the further
we get out here.
Or symmetrically, the further
we get out here, the more
certain we are that in that
particular symbol, neither a
plus or a minus was sent.
OK And it actually tuRns out,
if you work out the Gaussian
numbers, that beta k is the
log likelihood ratio up to
scale of the more likely
versus the log of the
likelihood, or the more likely
versus the less likely symbol.
So it has a minimum of 0.
The bigger it is, the
more reliable.
So it's natural to call
it the reliability.
OK.
An awful lot of traditional
algebraic decoding neglects
this channel down here.
It just says, OK, let's take
these hard decisions and try
to decode them.
If you've previously had a
coding class, then that's
probably what they did.
Or they assumed a context in
which this was never available
in the first place.
And my only point here, my main
point, is that that's a
very bad thing to do.
How can we evaluate that?
Suppose we just take this top
channel and don't look at the
reliability.
Then basically we have the
channel model becomes a binary
symmetric channel.
We have bits in, bits out, and
we have probably one minus p
that if we send a
0 we get a 0.
And since it's symmetric,
the same probability --
if we send a 1, we get a 1 --
and a probability p of
making an error.
So we get the traditional
memoryless binary symmetric
channel model.
We can compute the capacity of
this model and compare it to
the capacity of the additive
white Gaussian channel --
this model.
And depending on the signal to
noise ratio, from a capacity
calculation, we find that
there is of the order
of 2 or 3 dB loss.
Well, as we go on in this
course, we're going to find
that 1 dB is a very worthwhile
coding game.
So to throw away 2 or 3 dB just
by throwing away this
information, is a
bad thing to do.
I can make this point in a
different way by simply
looking at what's the optimum
decision rule.
For say, let me take very simple
code, just the 2-1-2
repetition code.
That's just 0,0,1,1.
This is the code where you
either send plus, plus, plus
alpha, plus alpha, or minus
alpha, minus alpha.
And what's the decision
region?
It's obviously this
45 degree line.
And what is this squared
distance to
any decision region?
It's 2 alpha squared, right?
So basically, the probability
of making an error is the
probability that the noise
variable has a magnitude in
this dimension, and in this
direction, greater than the
square root of 2
alpha squared.
You've been through all those
calculation several times now.
All right.
So this is -- if I keep
reliability info -- in other
words, if I keep the full
received signal -- if I
discard reliability, then
basically what can I get out?
Then my y, as I say, is in
0, 0, 0, 1, 1, 0, 1, 1.
There are only four possible
things I can see in two
transmissions through
this channel.
They're all binary two-tuples.
And what does that mean?
That means if my actual r is
in this quadrant, then I'm
going to make a hard decision
of 0 and 0 both times.
So I'm going to say I'm
in this quadrant.
And likewise, I'm basically
going to decide which of these
four quadrants I'm in, and
that's all the information the
decoder is going to have.
So here I am at this
point here.
Now the decoder simply knows,
via these two bits, which
quadrant you're in.
Now, it has to decide
which of these two
code words were sent.
What's its maximum likelihood
decision rule given just this
information?
AUDIENCE: 0, 0, [INAUDIBLE]
0, 0, [INAUDIBLE]
1, 1, 1, 1, 1.
And in the other
case, any one.
PROFESSOR: OK.
That's correct.
So clearly, if you land
in this quadrant,
you decide 0, 0.
Now, if you land down
here, you decide
1, 1 in this quadrant.
And what am I going to
do here or here?
Actually, here the evidence
is totally balanced.
I have nothing that tells
me whether to
go one way or another.
I could make an arbitrary
decision in the hope of
minimizing my error
probability.
Flip a coin.
But whichever decision I make,
what I'm going to find is that
there's a probability of error
that -- there's a certain
noise, namely the noise that
takes me from here to this
decision boundary that is
going to cause an error.
Or if I decide the other way, it
would be the one that goes
from here to here.
So I'm going to be stuck.
There are going to be certain
noise variables of length,
now, merely alpha, or square
distance alpha squared, that
are going to cause me to make a
decision error, ultimately.
Regardless of how I set up
this final block here.
Decoder.
Whatever rule I give to this
decoder, it's only going to
take, worst case, a noise of
squared magnitude alpha
squared to cause an error.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
I shouldn't have thrown
this away.
That's the elementary point
I'm trying to make here.
All right.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
the distance, d_min is
different, essentially.
I mean, we can put
it that way.
PROFESSOR: That's where I'm
going, is that the effective
minimum squared distance here
is 2 alpha squared.
And this is what shows up in
our union-bound estimate in
all of our --
we do this kind of minimum
distance decoding.
But if I throw away this
important information, then my
effective minimum
squared distance
is only alpha squared.
That is the bottom line here.
In dB terms, how much
of a cost is that?
3 dB, right?
So I've cost myself a factor
of 2 in noise margin.
So 3 dB loss.
Because of lack of time, I won't
go through the argument
in the notes, which shows that,
in fact, exactly the
same thing occurs for any --
whenever the minimum Hamming
distance is even here in this
code that I started from,
you lose precisely 3 dB.
It's not quite as clean an
argument when the minimum
Hamming distance is odd.
Then you lose up to 3 dB, and
it goes to 3 dB as the
distance increases.
But there's a very, pretty
elementary geometric argument
that hard decisions, again, cost
you 3 dB loss, which is
consistent with what
the capacity
calculation gives you.
All right.
Well, obviously the reason we
did this is we were trying to
simplify things.
What would be the first step to
unsimplify things and get
some of this loss back?
Let me suggest that what this
amounts to is a two-level
quantization of the received
real number rk.
What's the next number
higher than 2?
Integer.
AUDIENCE: 3.
PROFESSOR: 3.
All right.
How about a 3 level
quantization here?
OK.
So what we're talking about is
a highly quantized magnitude
where instead of just making a
decision boundary here, which
is effectively what we did for
2 level quantization, let's
make some null zone here between
some threshold plus t
and some threshold minus t.
And we'll say, in this region,
the received symbol is
unreliable.
OK.
That's called an erasure.
So we make a quantized
magnitude where rk --
doesn't fit so neatly here.
Let me just say this quantized
magnitude is going to give me
out something which is either
going to be minus 1,
a 0, or plus 1.
It's going to be three levels,
this is minus 1, 0, plus 1.
Or I don't want the
minus 1 there.
The reliability is either a
fixed reliability, or it's 0.
OK.
So now I've got a channel model
that looks like this.
If you work it out, it's called
the binary erasure
channel with errors.
All transitions are possible.
I can send a 0,1.
I can receive, let's call it,
a 0, a 1, or a question mark
for -- this is called
an erasure.
And this is 1 minus p minus q,
and this is p and this is q
symmetrically, for some p and
q, which you can evaluate.
And let's choose this threshold
t to optimize things
and get the maximum capacity.
Now if you do the capacity
calculation, you'll find
there's only 1 to 1.5 dB loss.
Again, depending on the
signal to noise ratio.
So in effect, you've already
bought back, just with this
very simple method, half of the
loss that you inflicted on
yourself by making
hard decisions.
So making erasures is a good
first step towards correcting
this problem.
And let's think about it again
for this simple code.
Suppose I establish these
thresholds at
plus t and minus t.
Plus t and minus t.
So now when I consider the
problem that the decoder has,
I have nine possible regions,
all right, each with three
possible decisions in
two dimensions.
And so what's my decision
rule going to be now?
For this 0, 0 decision, I'm
going to include, of course,
this region.
But now if I land in this
region, that means one of the
received symbols was erased,
but the other one gave me a
definite indication.
So the weight of evidence
still goes up here.
And similarly, like so.
So my decision region for 0 --
definitely for 0, 0
is this region.
And my decision region
definitely for 1, 1 is the
symmetric region.
And, of course, I still have
three regions where I really
can't say anything.
This is two erasures.
This is 0, 1 --
two conflicting pieces
of evidence.
This is 1, 0 -- two
conflicting pieces of evidence.
So I still have to flip
a coin out in here.
But how I improve things, that's
measured by what's the
minimum distance to --
what's the minimum size of
error it takes to make a
decision error.
And that's going to be either
this length or this length.
You see that?
Just pretty clear,
intuitively?
So the game here is we first of
all choose t so that these
two lengths are the same.
That's done by squeezing t.
You see these go in opposite
directions as t
is raised or lowered.
So we find the t such that
these two are the same.
Having equalized t, we find some
value for the effective
minimum squared distance, which
is between alpha squared
and 2 alpha squared.
As I remember, this somehow
gains about 1.5 dB.
The moral is about the same.
You can get about half of your
loss back by using erasures.
And again, this holds for any
code which has an even minimum
Hamming distance, if
you can accept
this method of analysis.
All right.
So a first step, even if you
want to stay in the binary
world, is to allow yourself
to use erasures as well.
That will claw back half of the
loss that you might have
incurred by using
hard decisions.
And, of course, even better
would be to use a more highly
quantized reliability and
somehow have a decoding
algorithm that can use
soft decisions.
Soft decisions are decisions
that have reliability metrics
attached to them.
And in the early
days of coding,
people evaluated capacity.
They evaluated this
sort of thing.
And it was pretty generally
agreed that eight level
quantization was going to be
practically good enough.
16 levels, certainly
good enough.
Nowadays you typically
go up to 64 levels.
You might go up to much higher
numbers if you have little
other things to worry
about like timing
recovery and so forth.
But if you're purely in a
synchronized, symbol by symbol
transmission, then three or
four bits of reliability
information are going
to be enough.
So from an engineering
point of view, that's
a good way to go.
Now, of course, you're going to
need a decoding algorithm
that can use soft decisions.
So as we go along, I'm going to
talk about error correcting
decoding algorithms that are not
much, because correcting
errors only is a very bad
thing to do here.
Errors and erasure.
Correcting decoding algorithms,
which are fairly
easy in algebraic
code context.
And then finally soft decision
decoding algorithms, which is
the kind we really want
on this channel.
We really want to use
the soft decisions.
We can't afford these
huge losses.
We can't even afford 1 to
1 and a 1/2 dB loss.
OK, so there's more set on
this in the last part of
chapter six, but that's
all the time I want to
spend on it in class.
Does anyone have
any questions?
yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
transformation before we do
the quantization, can we
change the shape of the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
regions such that we can
further improve the
[INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
improve the decoding?
PROFESSOR: Well, that's
an interesting idea.
But think about it from
an information
theoretic point of view.
Can you actually get more
information by introducing a
one-to-one transformation,
whether it's linear or
nonlinear, whatever?
AUDIENCE: The point is, the
original quantization is based
on a straight line,
[INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: You want to put a
curved line on this plane?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
That's going to imply decisions
that are not symbol
by symbol decisions.
That's going to imply that you
need to save r1 and r 2 in
order even to just decide where
you're in this and then
go through some kind of
quantization on the plane.
And once you've got r1 and r2
and you're trying to draw
crazy boundaries, I suggest it's
going to be simpler to
just compute the Euclidean
distance to each of these
points, which results in
this decision region.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
I don't see the rationale for
it yet, but there's been a
million innovations in this
business, and you
might have a good idea.
Any other comments?
I really appreciate comments
that go anywhere.
I like to address them now
when they're ripe.
OK.
So let's go on to chapter
seven and eight.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] here.
Chapters seven and eight
are closely related.
This is really my bow to
algebraic coding theory.
I expect that if any of you
have had a close course in
coding before, that it
was primarily on
algebraic coding theory.
How many of you have
had a course in
coding theory before?
One, two, three.
Not so many.
Was it on algebraic
coding theory?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
two, one
engineering and one algebraic.
PROFESSOR: Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: Two -- one for --
actually, two algebraic and
one out of kind of this stuff.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Well, you're a ringer then.
What was the one
on this stuff?
AUDIENCE: It was out
of Wicker's book.
PROFESSOR: Out of?
AUDIENCE: Wicker's book.
PROFESSOR: Wicker's book
on turbo codes.
AUDIENCE: No, the data
storage one.
PROFESSOR: Data storage.
OK.
I don't know that book.
But it talks about sophisticated
soft decision
type coding, and so forth.
What was the course you took?
AUDIENCE: Algebra.
PROFESSOR: Algebraic.
OK.
All right.
Well, let me just make a broad
brush comment, which may or
may not be supported
by your previous
exposure to coding theory.
Which is that for many, many
years, when people said coding
theory, they meant algebraic
coding theory, coding theory
of block codes that are
constructed by algebraic
techniques like Reed-Muller
codes, like Reed-Solomon
codes, BCH codes,
cyclic codes.
And if you said, I want to
leaRn some coding theory,
asked your graduate student to
go buy a textbook for you,
it's probably going to
be a textbook on
algebraic coding theory.
Meanwhile, there was a bunch
of us who were off actually
trying to construct codes
for real channels.
And conceRning with really how
complex this is to implement,
and what kind of performance
can we really get.
And we hardly ever used
algebraic codes.
Initially, we used convolutional
codes with
various kinds of decoding
algorithms, threshold
decoding, sequential decoding,
the Viterbi algorithm.
And these get more and more
elaborate, and then finally
the big step, well, the big
step was to capacity
approaching codes.
Which now people are starting to
call modeRn coding theory.
Long, random-like codes
that have an
iterative decoding algorithm.
And that's what we'll
get to towards
the end of this course.
So from an engineers point of
view, to some extent, of all
this work on n k d and algebraic
decoding algorithms
and so forth was a massive
distraction.
It really missed the point.
Sometimes because it assumed
hard decisions.
Or after assuming hard
decisions, it assumed bounded
distance decoding algorithms.
But it was all --
from Shannon's perspective, it
was too deterministic, too
constructed, too structured.
You want more random elements
in your coding scheme.
However, two things: one, this
theory is a beautiful theory,
both the mathematical theory
of finite fields and the
coding theory, particularly of
Reed-Solomon codes, which are
uniquely the greatest
accomplishment of algebraic
coding theory, and which have
proved to be very useful.
And B, Reed-Solomon codes are
something that as engineers,
ought to be part of your tool
kit, and you will find very
useful a variety
of situations.
So the objective of this part of
the course is, within some
proportion within the overall
scheme of the course, to give
you exposure to this
lovely theory.
You can leaRn all about it just
by reading a book or two.
Probably less than one book.
And to give you some exposure
to Reed-Solomon codes, which
have been used in practice.
For more than 20 years, the
deep space standard was a
concatenated code.
That means a sequence of two
codes, of which the inner code
was a convolutional code
decoded by the Viterbi
algorithm, which we'll talk
about after this.
And then the outer code, the
code that cleans up errors
made by the inner code, was a
Reed-Solomon code of length
255 over the finite field
with 256 elements.
And that's the dynamite
combination that dominated the
power-limited coding world
for at least 20 years.
So you ought to know,
as a minimum, about
Reed-Solomon codes.
So that's my objective
in going through
these next two chapters.
However, because these have
not basically been on the
winning path to get to the
Shannon limit, I'm trying to
limit it to three weeks max.
And therefore, that means that
the presentation is going to
be a lot faster than what
you're used to.
I'll probably do as much in
these three weeks as most
people do in a term in
an entire algebraic
coding theory course.
That's an exaggeration --
people do a lot more -- but I
try to at least hit all the
main points that you
need to know.
So I apologize in advance if it
seems that now we're on a
very fast moving train.
But you ought to know
this stuff.
You ought not to spend
too much time on it.
I'm trying to reconcile those
two points of view.
Any questions or comments?
All right.
Let's go.
Chapter seven.
We go through a series
of algebraic objects.
First, the integers,
then groups.
You certainly ought to know --
you do know about integers.
You ought to know about groups,
at least a little bit.
Let's see.
What's next?
Then fields, particularly
finite.
Then polynomials over fields,
particularly finite.
And then finally, from this we
actually get to construct
finite fields.
And these are all things that
you'll encounter again and
again, have encountered.
I think you've probably
encountered everything except
possibly for groups
and finite fields.
You certainly encountered
polynomials over real and
complex fields.
And so in some sense, this is
a broadening of what you
already know.
So I assume we start with the
integers for two reasons.
One is you already know about
the factorization properties
of the integers.
We're going to --
that leads to a little bit of
number theory, which we're
going to use when we talk about
groups, finite groups,
cyclic groups.
So this is just to remind
you, but it's
also to put up a template.
And we're going to find the
algebraic properties of
polynomials are very,
very similar to
those of the integers.
This is because they're
both rings.
They're both in fact principal
ideal domains.
They're Euclidean domains.
They both have a Euclidean
division algorithm as their
key mathematical property.
And so pretty much any time you
want to develop a result
about the polynomials, you can
start from the comparable
results that you know about the
integers and just change
the notation.
And you'll have a sketch of
the proof for polynomials.
So it's important to remind
ourselves about
the integers first.
Now, when I say the
factorization properties of
the integers, I'm not talking
about anything more
complicated than what you
leaRned in grade school.
I just want to introduce
a few terms.
We have the notion
of divisors.
a divides b means that a times
some quotient equals b.
I could be talking about plus or
minus, positive or negative
integers here.
Everything divides 0.
OK.
We have the idea of units,
which are the invertible
integers under multiplication.
And what are those?
Which integers have a
multiplicative inverse?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
any of them?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE].
All right.
That's a little exercise that
shows you that, in general,
the invertible elements of any
set that has an operation like
multiplication form a group.
[INAUDIBLE] group thing, these
clearly form a group under
multiplication that's
isomorphic
to the binary group.
Well, in fact, we've already
been using it --
F2.
OK.
So we have units, and whenever
we talk about the divisors,
factorization, primes,
so forth,
the units are a nuisance.
Because we can always multiply
things by units and it doesn't
affect factorization
properties.
This is [UNINTELLIGIBLE] a
little bit more out there.
What I eventually want
to get to is --
skipping a few things that
are said in the notes --
is unique factorization.
Maybe before that I should
define primes:
are positive integers.
The reason we stay positive
is, again --
of course, we could have a
negative prime integer, but
let's pick a unique
representative of two units.
Positive integers --
I should've said in the notes
greater than 1, we don't
consider 1 to be a prime --
that have no non-trivial
divisors.
And, of course, every integer
has trivial divisors.
Namely, plus or minus 1 and
plus or minus itself.
Let me give this a name.
i.
Not a very good name.
How about n?
So if we have any integer n,
it's divisible by plus or
minus one, plus or minus n --
that doesn't count.
So a prime is an integer that
doesn't have any other
divisors than these
trivial ones.
And then I want to get to unique
factorization, which
I'll just state, not prove.
Which is that every integer
is equal to a
unique product of primes.
And we always have to
add up to units.
We can add as many plus or minus
1's to the product as we
want, as long as we have
an even number of them.
And we'll have another
factorization, so here, we
want to exclude the units.
And then we have unique
factorization.
OK.
This is all grade school
stuff, high
school stuff maybe.
Again, when I go through
polynomials, you'll see there
is a set of concept
exactly like this.
Now, where we want to get to
is mod-n arithmetic, which
again, you all know
about, I assume.
This is based on the fact --
we can think of it as being
based on Euclidean division
algorithm, which basically
proves that given any two
integers m and n, we can write m
as some qn plus r where 0 is
less than or equal to r, less
than or equal to n minus 1,
and is called the remainder
of m, modulo n.
And how is this proved?
Let's say these are both
positive integers.
Say m is a big integer,
n is a small integer.
We just keep subtracting integer
multiples of n from m
until we --
you know, the remainder will
start decreasing until we get
the remainder in this range, and
it's obvious that we can
always get a remainder
that's in that range.
And further, that this
decomposition is unique under
this restriction on r.
All right.
So we write the m is congruent
or equivalent to r mod n.
That means it differs from r by
a multiple of n where r is
unique and r is in the set 0, 1,
up through n minus 1, which
we say are the residue
classes mod n.
It has to be one of
those n things.
OK?
No one is having the slightest
trouble with this, right?
Boring.
You've seen it all before.
I hope.
OK.
So now you ask, suppose m equals
r mod-n, and some other
w equals s mod-n.
What is m plus w mod-n, and you
quickly prove that it's
equal to r plus s mod-n.
By transferring, by just
checking the properties of
ordinary arithmetic, you can use
this kind of expression: m
must equal something
times n plus r.
w must equal something
times n plus s.
So if we add m plus w, we're
going to get something times n
plus r plus s.
And that is, by definition,
going to be r plus s mod-n.
So we get a well-defined
addition rule for these
residues, for the elements of
this set of n residues Rn, or
remainders.
OK, so addition is
well-defined.
And similarly, multiplication
is well-defined.
mw mod-n, again, you can prove
-- and this is done
in the notes --
that if mw mod-n can be
found by taking rs and
reducing it, mod-n.
Maybe I should have congruent
signs here, but I
won't worry about it.
So this is mod-n, addition
and multiplication.
So what this says is that Rn,
combined with this mod-n
addition operation, which in the
notes I write in that way,
and this mod-n multiplication
operation --
this is a well-defined set of n
elements with a well-defined
addition operation and
a well-defined
multiplication operation.
And I don't prove any properties
about it here, but
I come back to prove that this
has almost all of the
properties that we
want of a field.
In fact, if n is a prime, it
does have the properties that
we want of a field.
So we'll later prove that the
finite field with p elements
is simply rp with mod-p addition
and multiplication.
And, of course, for the
particular case p equals 2, we
already have a lot of experience
with this.
That's how we get the
binary field.
We just take the 0 and 1,
considered as residues mod-2.
And then the field addition and
multiplication operations
give us something that
satisfies the
axioms of the field.
We'll find that works for every
prime, and it doesn't
work for non-primes.
Can anyone quickly see why this
isn't going to work for
non-primes?
Suppose n equals 6.
Anyone quickly see why this set
under these two operations
isn't going to be a field?
This, of course, assumes that
you know what a field is,
which we haven't actually
said yet.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Excuse me?
PROFESSOR: There's no inverse.
In a field, every non-zero
element has to have an
inverse, just like in the
real and complex field.
But in the integers mod-6, 3
times 2 is equal to 6, which
is equal to 0.
So there are two non-zero
elements that multiplied
together give 0.
And that means that neither 3
nor 2 can possibly have a
multiplicative inverse.
So that's why you have
to have a prime.
This doesn't happen, of course,
if n were a prime.
OK.
So that's just a little warm
up to remind you what mod-n
arithmetic is like.
And in particular, this is going
to be the key element of
a lot of proofs --
the Euclidean division
algorithm --
both for integers and
for polynomials.
OK.
So that, I hope, was review.
Now we're going to talk
about groups.
So let's do it.
How many of you feel you
know what a group is?
Less than half the class.
OK.
Well, we've been talking about
groups so far here, but let's
take a little bit more of
an axiomatic approach.
In the notes, I actually give
two possible sets of axioms
for a group.
Let me start with
a standard one.
You've heard of something called
the group property in
this course.
Well, first of all, what am I
talking about when I'm talking
about a group?
I'm talking about a set, g,
and I'm also talking about
some operation on that set,
which I'll use the mod
addition circle-plus as
the group property.
Even if it's multiplication or
matrix inversion or -- no, it
couldn't be matrix inversion.
What this means is that if we
take any two elements of the
group, then a plus b
is well-defined.
So you can think there's
a table.
Here are the elements
of the group.
a, b, c, d, e.
And at this point, all we
know is that we can
fill out the table.
We get something that
goes in all here.
All right?
So that defines the group.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: That means if I
give a and b, then the
quantity a plus b is --
I can tell you what c is.
There's a unique element in
each of the cells of this
addition table, or
the group table.
OK.
Group property, also called
closure, is the obvious one.
What's an elementary condition
of what all these sums have to
be for this to be a group?
Have to be all in the group.
If I say I have a group that
consists of 1,2,3,4,5,
1,2,3,4,5 and my group
operation is ordinary
addition, then I can certainly
fill out the table.
And I get 2,3,4,5,6 --
whoops.
Yeah, that's the element that's
not in the group.
So in order to have a
group, I want a --
I mean, it's a plus b is in
the group, all a and b.
So the group is closed
under addition.
This was the property we used to
define linearity for binary
linear block codes.
The sum of any two n-tuples
had to be another
n-tuple in the code.
We have the associativity
operation.
This is a requirement on the
binary operation, really.
a plus b plus c has got to be
equal to a plus b plus c.
In other words, you can get
rid of the parentheses.
And this, an expression like
that, is meaningful.
It doesn't matter how you group,
whether you add these
two things first and then that,
or add these two things
first and then that.
Maybe now is a good time to
talk about the special
property, which is
not an axiom.
So let me call it x abelian, or
the commutative property.
This is true if a plus
b is equal to b
plus a, all a, b group.
Now this is, of course, true
for ordinary addition and
ordinary multiplication.
It's not true for matrix
multiplication.
Say if I have a group of
matrices, then in general, ab
is not equal to ba.
So for some groups this
holds, for some
groups it doesn't hold.
In this course, almost without
exception, every group we're
going to talk about is
an abelian group.
That means that in adding
things up, the
order doesn't matter.
So if that were true, then it in
a plus b plus c, that means
that's the same as c plus
b plus a, or c plus
a plus b, or whatever.
All the properties that
you're accustomed to
from ordinary addition.
But this is not one of the group
axioms, and, of course,
there are non-abelian groups.
The smallest non-abelian group
has size 6, and is the
permutation group on
three elements.
So small groups are all --
size 5 or less are
all abelian.
Because that's the only way
we can do the group table.
All right.
So that's terminology
at this point.
It's not part of the axiom.
But that's the reason that I use
a symbol that looks like a
plus, is I'm pretty much always
thinking an abelian
group, and I don't want to
trouble you with thinking
about non-abelian groups.
OK.
Then we have the identity
property.
There is an identity, which,
in an abelian group, is
always called --
ordinarily called 0.
In an additive group it's
always called 0.
So I'll call it 0.
In more abstract treatments,
it's called 1 or E for --
what does E stand for?
Eigen something.
There's a 0 in g such that
0 plus a equals --
or a plus 0 --
is always equal to a.
The 0 is the null operator on
any element of the group.
If you add 0 to anything, you
get what you started with.
Clearly, we have such a thing
in ordinary addition.
Suppose I was talking in
the real numbers under
multiplication, is that
a group, you guess?
It's actually not.
Suppose I talk about the
non-zero real numbers under
multiplication.
Is that a group?
Yes, and its identity is 1.
1 as the thing that if you
multiply it by anything, it
leaves what you started with.
There's the inverse, which we
don't have in the reals under
multiplication.
For all a and g, there exists
something called minus a --
or a to the minus 1 in
multiplicative notation --
in g such that a plus
minus a equals 0.
That's an additive inverse.
So in the real numbers, the
inverse of a is minus a.
In the integers, the
inverse of a is
minus a under addition.
In the non-zero real numbers
under multiplication, every
non-zero real number does have
a multiplicative inverse,
which is called 1 over
a, or a minus 1.
That's why we have
to exclude 0.
0 does not an inverse.
So a good example to think
about is r-star, which is
non-zero reals under ordinary
multiplication, is a group.
Is it an abelian group?
Is ab equal to ba?
Yeah.
So this is an infinite
abelian group.
All right.
OK.
I want to show that
the axioms lead to
a permutation property.
Because this is something
that's going to come
up again and again.
One way of saying this is if I
have, if a plus b equals c --
suppose I write down that
symbolic equation --
then I can solve for any
one of the three
given the other two.
How would I do that?
If I'm given a and b, obviously,
that tells me c
from the table.
If I'm given a and c, then a
is equal to c minus b --
I'm sorry -- b is equal
to c minus a.
I should say here, from this
inverse, we're going to write
b plus minus a in
a simpler form.
It's just b minus a.
So the fact that we have an
inverse sort of defines
another operation, which
we call subtraction,
which is not abelian.
Not commutative.
a minus b is not equal
to b minus a.
But it's basically implicit
in this that we
subtract group elements.
We can cancel group elements.
If you have a plus c equal
to b plus c, then a
must be equal to b.
Because you can subtract
c from both sides.
All right.
OK.
What does this mean that this
gives us a constraint on the
addition table of a group?
Suppose I take a four element
group, g, and one of the
elements is going to be the zero
element, and the other
let's just call a, b, c.
0, a, b, c.
And I have a well-defined
addition table, which
includes, in here, only
a 0, a, b, c.
From the property of the
identity, I can fill in some
of these things.
And now what freedom do I have
to fill in the rest?
How many group tables are
there of size four?
Well, the main point that I want
to make with permutation
property is that every row and
every column has to be a
permutation of the four
elements 0, a, b, c.
Why is that?
Suppose I had another a
in this column here.
Then I would have a plus 0 is
equal to a, and also a plus c
is equal to a.
But that would imply that c
equals 0, which it isn't.
All right.
So in order to be able to solve
this equation, this has
to be something different
from a, and likewise.
Since I have, in this case, a
finite group, I basically just
have to write the group elements
down here again in
some order.
It tuRns out that for four
elements, there are exactly
two ways of doing that,
generically.
One is sort of the
cyclic group.
I'm sorry --
a, b, c, 0, a, c, 0, a, b.
That's one way of filling out
the table such that each row
is a permutation
of 0, a, b, c.
Each column is a permutation
So that's a legitimate
group table.
Let me just, for your interest,
show you that that's
not the only one.
We could also do 0, a,
b, c, 0, a, b, c.
If I write 0 here, then
I've got to write
c there and b there.
Got to write c here
and b there.
And then down here, the only
choice I have is this.
This is called the cyclic
group of four elements.
This is called the
Klein four group.
And this is all there is.
Both of them tuRn out to be
abelian if you check it out.
And basically, this permutation
property restricts
these to be the possible groups
of size four, abelian
or non-abelian, just to
satisfy the axiom.
I actually prove in the notes
that if you replace axioms a
and b with the permutation
property, you get another
equivalent set of axioms
for a group.
So the permutation of properties
is very basic.
All you need is --
for a set and a binary operation
to form a group, all
you need is identity,
associativity, and the
permutation property for
the group table,
the addition table.
Simple proof of that
in the notes.
But this observation
is going to be
important as we go forward.
It's a fundamental thing
we're going to use.
So you see a group can't
just be anything.
It already has very definite
restrictions on it.
All right.
Anything else I want
to say right here?
OK, subtraction, cancellation.
OK, I guess we can go into
the next property,
which is cyclic groups.
And I'm only going to talk about
finite cyclic groups, or
finite groups in general.
Now, a cyclic group
is probably the
simplest kind of group.
Let me first put up the
canonical cyclic group, which
is the integers mod-n, which
means the set of residues
mod-n and the mod-n addition
operation.
Which is written just as Zn --
there are various notations
for it.
But this, of course, we'll
just write it as Zn.
The integers mod-n.
Does this form a group?
Let's check the axioms.
Certainly, let's take
the original axioms.
So the Rn is closed under
addition mod-n.
If we add two elements, we're
going to get another element.
The mod-n addition operation
is associative.
In fact, it's abelian.
a plus b plus c is b plus c plus
a -- it doesn't matter
what order, from the
same property
for ordinary addition.
Is there an identity in here?
Yes.
The 0 is one of the elements
here and acts as the identity.
0 plus anything mod-n is equal
to the same thing mod-n.
And is there an inverse?
OK.
Let's explicitly write out Rn
as 0, 1 up to n minus 1.
And then I claim that if I take
any of these i, then n
minus i is its inverse.
n minus i is in the right
range if not zero.
The inverse of 0 is 0.
The inverse of i between 1 and
n minus 1 is going to be n
minus i because if I add
i to n minus i --
is equal to n, take mod-n,
that's equal to 0.
So every element has the
additive inverse.
And so the group table has a
very boring form, which does
satisfy the permutation
property.
If I take Z5, for instance.
0,1,2,3,4.
0 plus anything looks
like that.
1 times anything is
just 1,2,3,4 and 1
plus 4 is 0 mod 5.
2,3,4,0,1, and so forth.
3, 4, 0, 1, 2, 4, 0, 1, 2, 3.
Each row or column is just a
cyclic shift to the previous
row or column.
Just fill it out.
And does it satisfy the
permutation property?
Yes, it does.
This one here, for instance, you
can recognize as a cyclic
group table.
And so, apart from relabeling,
this is the group table of Z4.
Or we take a, b, c
equal to 1, 2, 3.
If two groups have the same
group table up to relabelling,
they're said to be isomorphic.
OK?
That's an important
concept in math.
And all it means is the two
groups act the same, except
that we've changed the names
of the group elements.
OK.
So what I'm going to show
is that all cyclic --
this group is sort of cyclic
because, as you see in the
notes, we can think of adding
1 as just being
cycling around a circle.
In this case, with
5 points on it.
And adding 2 is going two
steps around the circle.
And the elements on the
circle are the group
elements 0, 1, 2, 3, 4.
And then we get to 5.
We identify that with 0.
So we close the loop.
One we identify with 6.
This with 7.
This with 8.
Up to as many as you like.
So that's the intuition
why these are
called cyclic groups.
The addition operation cycles
rather than being on a line,
as it would be with the ordinary
integers, where we go
infinitely in either
direction.
So the formal definition of a
cyclic group is that g has a
single generator.
Call it a little g.
And -- am I running over?
Close to.
Is that really right?
I only have five minutes left.
We're not going to go at
the speed I had hoped.
g is --
what does that mean?
If we know that g contains g,
and this is never going to be
equal to 0, then we know that
g contains two elements at
least: 0 and g.
And by the group axioms, g
contains g, g plus g, g
plus g plus g --
we can keep adding them.
I'm going to call these the
integer multiples of g.
So this will be 1g, 2g, 3g.
That's what I mean when
I write an integer
in front of g --
I mean g plus itself, the
integer number of times.
And all those things, by the
group properties, have to be
in the group.
All right?
Again, restrict this
to finite.
It's a finite cyclic group.
Then at some point,
I have to --
this is all the elements
of the group.
So at some point, I have
to come along and
say that ng is 0.
If just by --
when I say generator, the
set generated by g is
just 1g, 2g, 3g.
And that's got to be all the
elements of the group, so n
times g has got to be 0.
And that means, without putting
too fine a point on
it, that if n were 5, for
instance, the group has to
consist of 0g, 1g, 2g, 3g, 4g,
and then 5g is equal to 0.
So we call this 0g or 5g.
And furthermore, the addition
table of the group, we can,
you know --
however, if we add 2 g's to 3
g's, we're going to 5 g's,
which is 0.
All right?
So 2g plus 3g has got to
be 5 g's, which is 0g.
So this is what the addition
table of the
group has to look like.
It's exactly the same, except
we just make a one-to-one
correspondence like that.
So the conclusion is a
finite cyclic group
with n elements --
I'll write the size of g by this
absolute value thing --
is isomorphic to the
integers mod-n --
this canonical cyclic group
that we started with --
must be isomorphic to Zn with
the isomorphism being given by
the one-to-one correspondence.
i_g in the group corresponds
to simply i in Zn, or 0 is
less than or equal to
i is less than or
equal to n minus 1.
The addition rule is
exactly the same.
OK, so this is a pretty
sweeping conclusion.
It says that really the only
finite cyclic group up to
relabeling is Zn.
OK, so if you understand Zn,
you understand all finite
cyclic groups.
Just in a general group, we're
going to have some element
which basically represents 1,
called g, and its integer
multiples, which represent
2, 3, 4, and so forth.
But we can operate with
a group just as
though it was Zn.
So it's easy to understand
finite cyclic groups.
They all just look like this.
Question?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is the generator
unique?
PROFESSOR: No, it's not.
No, it's not.
Next time we'll start
to talk about
subgroups of Zn, for instance.
In the set of Z5 --
well, let me take this.
All right.
In Z5 --
let me not even do that.
In Z5, 1 is the generator, but
because 5 is a prime, 2 is a
generator, too.
All right?
Another way of writing.
Let's take a generator
equals 2 in Z5.
Then g equals 2, 2g equals 4.
3g equals 6, equals 1 mod-5.
4g equals 3.
And 5g, of course, equals
5, which equals zero.
So 2 is also a generator.
And, in fact, 3 and 4
are also generators.
There are four generators.
This is getting us right
into the number theory.
OK.
So no, g does not
have to be 1.
g is just something that if
you take all its integer
multiples, you generate
the group.
OK, I guess we stop there, and
we'll resume next time.